et je suis est très bouleversée depuis
le début de l'émission pardonnez moi je
vais finir mes phrases mais l'exclusion
de la famille je reconnais que vous êtes
d'information le frère ou la soeur qui
vous imitent jusqu'à vous envoyer
jusqu'à vouloir maintenant je me
reconnais que vous êtes d'informatique
donnez moi tout ce que vous dites on
reconnaît que vous êtes un enfant battu
la seule différence est que justement
tout les expertises que lorsqu'on a été
battue ou bien en humiliation tôt ou
bien on se bat quand toutes les
humiliations et ma question pour faire
simple c'est que j'ai l'impression vous
savez choisi d'humilier à votre tour
involontairement parce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure je n'arrivais plus à me
dire que je m'en prenais à tous ceux qui
étaient faibles et même les zips les
décès antisémite prouve que vous avez
été un enfant battu
et lorsqu'on a été un enfant battu je
peux vous dire qu'on comprend tout ce
que vous dites tout ce que vous dites et
qu'on ne laisse pas une seconde
une seule seconde place au doute
pardonnez moi
[Applaudissements]
je me suis bien entraîné je suis bien
non mais de paix qui parle depuis la
première fois qu'ils parlent
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que et
honnêtement il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui ne comprennent pas mais je peux vous
dire quelle catégorie de personnes qui
ont été battus et qui vous comprennent
et vous savez en france il n'ya pas
d'étude sur les enfants battus devenu
adulte il y en a pas y en a aux états
unis d'un en grande bretagne canada les
autres pays mais aucune étude quasiment
sur ce que sont devenus des enfants
adultes lorsqu'ils sont devenus grands
pourquoi parce qu'en france il un vrai
déni
il ya un vrai tabou et c'est ce tabou
dont vous souffrez aujourd'hui et je
encore encore une petite case à cocher
systématiquement la victime est
considéré comme coupable systématique
outre le fait que vous m'avez beaucoup
ce soir christine vous dit quelque chose
qui est très important cyril je viens
d'apercevoir d'une chose ce soir
depuis que mon livre est sorti on a
parlé de tout sauf de l'enfance battue
c'est le seul sujet dont on n'a jamais
parlé aurait pas eu de débat société
savoir ce que j'ai fait qui dit quoi que
quelqu'un de sortie de l'hôpital
psychiatrique dit ceci cela la seule
chose qui n'a pas été traité et je viens
de le réaliser
vous rendez compte là à l'instant en
direct dans votre émission
il n'y a pas eu un débat à une seconde
consacrée à l'enfance battu et je crois
que la france est un des pays qui donc
ce domaine a malheureusement bat des
records absolument terrible et je vous
viennent vous venez de me faire réaliser
qu'on a parlé de tout depuis le mois
d'août sauf des enfants vous savez qu'à
l'heure où on parle en ce moment et des
enfants dans des placards les enfants
qui viennent de faire brûler à coups de
cigarettes et des enfants qui viennent
de se faire jeter dans leur bain
bouillon vous avez souvent y avait des
émissions dans les 80 sur les enfances
battu des caves une émission comme ça je
coupais la radio je ne supporte pas ce
sujet la seule manière que j'ai réussi
pour dire la seule manière le seul livre
que j'ai réussi à lire sur l'enfance
battue c'est celui
j'ai écrit à pouvoir lire sur l'enfance
battu j'étais obligé d'écrire le livre
moi même
est ce que vous dites c'est qu'en fait
tout ce qui s'est passé le blocage des
parents le frère les avocats machin
c'est pour mettre une chape de plomb sur
un tableau qui l'enfance battu les
femmes violées je ne veux pas comparer
on arrive à en parler et heureusement je
veux pas qu'on parlait cause c'est
ridicule mais il ya un sujet dont on
entend le harcèlement à l'école je suis
heureux qu'on en parle en parler de
maltraitance les animaux on en parle
beaucoup et c'est un c'est très
important parce que c est ça ressemble
en fait et les enfants martyrs jamais
parme
pourquoi c'est là je n'ai pas la réponse
pourquoi par semaine il ya deux à trois
enfants qui meurent sous les coups de
leurs parents en france voilà au
téléroman ce chiffre c'est assez
incroyable merci en tout cas christine
ce témoignage merci ma chérie 2007
[Applaudissements]